Travis is with us in Florida hi Travis
how are you better than I deserve what's
up oh well I found your podcast about a
year ago and was doing a lot of driving
at the time and basically listening to
everyone and I could get on my phone and
in the last year we've knocked out about
thirty five thousand dollars in credit
card debt and it's been over a year
since we use a credit card
good for you really thanks and so with
the trucks and as of today I'm starting
a second job to bring in an extra
thousand bucks months because we're
trying to go to violent ends and the
question that I have is around the car
that we bought last year and if we
should keep it or sell it how much do
you owe on it we have 31 on it how much
other debt have you got other than that
we have a hundred and forty and student
loans and militate that what's your
household income um as of today it's 132
and when I start to need job next week
it'll go up to 140 okay um that's a car
you could afford if it were paid off and
you were debt free but it's a very very
big car loan while you're facing
$100,000 of student loan debt
so we're I in your shoes I'd move down
to about a ten thousand dollar car
that's what I was wondering because I
didn't have this payoff the next five or
six months but there's all that equity
sitting there that we could be using to
pay off the student loans so we've been
talking you could it you could have
thirty thousand dollars worth of student
loan debt paid off in that same period
of time right right yeah ever since you
started listen to you I've always
thought you know wwt be what would Dave
do and my wife isn't always on board
with that and trying to decide if I'm
being too hard or if she's been you know
well it's not it's not a freak out thing
I mean it's not you know jumping up and
down like you're an idiot or something
but it is a it is a big old chunky car
loan and it is you know it's gonna slow
down your get out of debt plan by
probably a year and a half or two years
it's pretty tough